hallo zusammen mein Adventskalender 2023
ist endlich da und ich darf ihn euch
heute präsentieren wer unseren
Newsletter abonniert hat der hat sogar
schon die Information erhalten also hier
ist der Adventskalender den es ab
November gibt ab jetzt aber schon
vorbestellbar er wiegt sage und schreibe
8,5 Kilo und er ist voll geparkt mit
vielen vielen tollen Dingen mit über der
Hälfte neuen Artikeln die ich extra für
den Adventskalender konzipiert und
entwickelt habe das ist praktisch eine
Neuheit und es sind wirklich ganz tolle
Artikel enthalten wie zum Beispiel auch
eine nagelneue Backform aber ich will
auch gar nicht so viel spoilern denn ich
will nicht zu viel verraten es sind
wirklich tolle Artikel drin zum Backen
zum Kochen zum Naschen mit Heim wirklich
richtig schön er ist toll gemacht ich
habe ihn auch so entwickelt dass man
praktisch einen schönen Karton hat eine
schöne Verpackung und wenn man ihn auch
macht hat man hier einzelne Verpackungen
mit dabei die wirklich alle wunderschön
geworden sind und ich finde es ist
einfach eine schöne Geschenk so kann man
sich die Vorweihnachtszeit versüßen
entweder sich selbst oder einfach
jemanden den man gerne hat ich habe hier
auch eine Startbox in dieser Startbox
findet ihr Briefe und könnt praktisch
aus der Startbox bei Tür Nummer eins
Brief Nummer eins rausnehmen und habe
dann einfach noch was von mir
persönliches geschrieben in eurer Box
und das Ganze ist wirklich schön weil
wirklich 24 Türchen vollgeschrieben sind
und es steht entweder was zu den Artikel
mit dabei oder einfach was schönes denn
der Adventskalender heißt ja auch twenty
four Stories auf happiness und der soll
euch einfach 24 Tage lang glücklich
machen
krass oder das alles steckt hier in
dieser adventskalenderbox und ich habe
mir gedacht ich überrasche euch jetzt
denn ich weiß auch nicht ab wann er
ausverkauft sein wird deswegen verlose
ich in diesem Video auf allen vier
großen Plattformen Instagram tiktok
Youtube und Facebook einen
Adventskalender für euch schreibt dafür
einfach gerne in die Kommentare ob wir
ihn für euch für eine Freundin für einen
Freund für die Eltern oder für wen auch
immer gewinnen wollt und dann werden wir
das Gewinnspiel eine Woche laufen lassen
werden dann die Gewinner auslosen und ab
November wird dann der Adventskalender
versendet jetzt gibt's ihn zum
Vorteilspreis zum Vorverkaufspreis für
199 € und ab dem Zeitpunkt ab dem der
Vorverkauf dann beendet ist gibt's ihn
dann zum regulären Preis was ich noch
sagen muss der Warenwert liegt bei 380 €
und ihr seht hier auch schon an den
Größen der Verpackungen es sind ganz
viele verschiedene Artikel drin keine
probegrößen keine testgrößen und
eigentlich wirklich wie gesagt über die
Hälfte neue Artikel das andere sind
Sally Artikel die man einfach haben muss
in der Küche zum Kochen auch Backen
Artikel die man sich einfach immer sehr
sehr wünscht und ich freue mich dass er
jetzt endlich verfügbar ist denn wir
haben wirklich die letzten Monate viel
dran gearbeitet und ich bin richtig
stolz auf meinen Kalender und danach
wenn ihr alles ausgepackt habt habt ihr
hier einen schönen großen Karton den ihr
dann noch zum Verstauen verwenden könnt
zum Verschenken oder einfach für den
Kleiderschrank fürs Büro fürs
Kinderzimmer ich finde es wirklich
wahnsinnig schön und hoffe dass er euch
auch gefällt ich bin richtig happy